hi everyone I'm Abbi if you weren't here
last week I'm the head T of this class
and this is the second of three lectures
that I'm going to be giving on RN ends
and related topics okay so welcome to
week 4 today we're going to be learning
about vanch ingredients and some more
complex types of iron atoms so before we
get started I've got a few announcements
the first announcement is that
assignment 4 is released today
it's G's Thursday of next week not
Tuesday so that means you have two days
more to do it than you did for all the
other homeworks and the reason for that
is assignment 4 is probably more work
than the other homework so far so don't
be surprised by that assignment 4 is all
about neural machine translation and
we're going to learn about nmt on
Thursday's lecture this week and this is
really exciting because actually CS 2 to
4 and has never had an nmt assignment
before so this is all new this year and
you're going to be the first year of
students you're going to be doing and
then empty assignment something else
that's different about assignment 4 is
that you're going to be using Azure
which is a cloud computing service in
order to train your nmt systems on a
virtual machine with the GPU and this is
necessary in order to be able to do it
in a reasonable amount of time so I have
a warning which is if you're a person
who perhaps doesn't have a lunch a lot
of experience working on remote machines
so for example if you're not very
familiar with SSH or T marks or remote
text editing then I advise you to budget
some extra time for assignment 4 because
that's probably going to take you a
little while to set up and get used to
so again I'm going to emphasize do get
started early on assignment 4 because
the nmt system takes about 4 hours to
train on your virtual machine so you
really can't start it the night before
and expect to get it in on time and the
cyma 4 is really quite a lot more
complicated than assignment 3 so don't
get into a false sense of security if
you found assignment 2 easy so Thursday
slides on nmt are already on the website
today so you can even start looking at
those today if you want if you want to
get started in assignment for early as I
have a few more announcements on the
subject of projects next week's lectures
are going to be all about projects
you're gonna hear about question
answering and the default font of
projects and then you're also going to
get some tips about how you
I choose and define your own custom
projects so it's fine if you're not
thinking about project this week that's
okay you can delay until next week to
start thinking about it for the first
time but if you are a person who's
already thinking about your projects for
example if you're trying to choose your
custom projects then you should check
out the websites project page because
has quite a lot of information about how
to choose your projects and also some
inspiration and that includes we've
collected some project ideas from
various members of the Stanford AI lab
so these are faculty and PhD students
and postdocs who have ideas for an RPG
planning projects that they would like
cs2 different students such as yourself
to work on so especially if you're
looking to maybe get into research later
this is a really great opportunity to
work with someone in the staff they are
lab and maybe get some mentorship as
well okay
so here's an overview last week we
learned about recurrent neural networks
and we learned about why they're really
great for language modeling and today
we're gonna learn about some problems
with our lens and we're gonna learn
about how to fix them and this is going
to make best motivates us to learn about
some more complex RNN variants and then
next lecture on Thursday we're going to
have some more application based content
so we're going to be learning about
neural machine translation which is a
really important task in NLP and deep
learning and in particular gonna learn
about this architecture called sequence
the sequence of is attention but in more
detail today's lecture first we're going
to learn about the vanishing gradient
problem and this is going to motivate us
to learn about two new types of RNN
called long short term memory and gated
recurrent units we Rustica learn about
some other kind of miscellaneous fixes
for the vanishing gradient problem or
the exploding gradient problem
so in particular we learned about
gradient clipping which is fairly simple
but quite important and we're also going
to learn about skip connections which is
a fairly new neural architecture which
tries to fix the banchon grading problem
and then at the end of lecture we'll
learn about some more fancy RNN variants
such as bi-directional Arianna RNs
those the ones which go not just left to
right but also right to left and we're
going to learn about multi-layer RNAs
and that's when you stack multiple or an
ads on top of each other so there's a
lot of important definitions today so
you're going to find that the
information in this lecture is pretty
important for assignment four and prob
your project as well okay so let's get
started thinking about the vanish
ingredients so here we have an RNN with
let's say four steps and supposed to be
have some kind of loss that's J fall and
that's computed based on the fourth
hidden stage so let's suppose we're
interested in asking what is the
derivative of this last J fall with
respect to the hidden states h1 the
first hidden States so I'm representing
that with this blue arrow notation to
kind of represent how we have to make
the gradients flow backwards in order to
compute this so if we're interested in
what this gradient is we can apply the
chain rule and say well it's the product
of the gradients of the loss with
respect to H 2 and then gradient of H 2
where the respect to H 1 and then
similarly we can decompose that again
using the chain rule and we can do it
again so what we've done here is we've
decomposed the gradient that we were
interested in into the products of these
various intermediate gradients and then
particularly we're seeing all these HT
by HT minus 1 adjacent gradients of the
hidden States so the thing I want to ask
you is what happens if these gradients
are small given that there's a lot of
them what happens if they're small in
magnitude
so the overall problem of the vanishing
gradient problem is that when these
gradients are small then our overall
gradient is going to get smaller and
smaller as it back propagates further
because the accumulated gradient is the
product of all of these intermediate
gradients and when you multiply
something by something small then the
whole thing gets smaller so that's what
I'm representing here with these smaller
and smaller blue arrows going backwards
so that's a general idea of the
vanishing gradient problem here's a
slightly more formal definition so if
you remember from last time if we have a
new RNN then the hidden state HT is
computed as a function of the previous
hidden state HT minus 1 and the current
input XT so you might remember in the
previous lecture we said that XT were
one hot wet vectors representing words
and then et is the embedding this
lecture we're going to be getting rid of
that detail and we just
be thinking very abstractly about an RNN
that has some kind of input XT and XT is
just any kind of vector probably a dense
vector but you know it could be words or
not it could be one hard core dense but
that's just the input so that's the
definition that we learnt last time for
vanilla or an ounce so this means that
the derivative of HT hidden states on
step T with respect to the previous
hidden state is this expression here so
this is just an application of the chain
rule and if you look at it long enough
for refer back to the back prop lecture
you'll see
does that make sense so in particular
we're multiplying by WH at the end
because we have the multiplication of WH
and HT minus 1 on the inside ok so if
you remember on the previous slide we
were thinking about what's the gradient
of the loss on some step step a let's
say with respect to a hidden state HJ on
some previous step J and maybe J is
quite a few steps before I so we can now
write this in the following way so just
by playing the chain rule then on the
first line was saying that this
derivative that we're interested in can
be decomposed into the derivative with
respect to step I which is kind of the
last step and then do all of those
intermediate gradients of the adjacent
hidden states as well so that that first
slide is just exactly the same thing as
we were looking at on the the picture
the diagram on the previous slide ok and
then given that we figured out what is d
HT by d h t minus 1 further up the
slides and we can just substitute that
in so what we're finding is that this
overall gradient that we're interested
in in particular has this term wh the
weight matrix and it's multiplied by
itself I minus J times because there's I
minus J many steps between step J and
step I which is the distance that we're
traveling with this gradient so the big
problem here is if this weight matrix W
H is small then this term is going to
get vanishingly small exponentially
small as I and J get further apart so to
give this a little more detail we can
think about the l2 matrix norms of all
of these matrices right
and as a as a so sorry I'm it's a known
fact of l2 norms that you have this
inequality that the norm of the products
of some matrices is less than equal to
the product of the norms of the matrices
so in particular we're seeing that the
norm of this gradient that we're
interested in is less than or equal to
the product I minus J many times of the
norm of the way matrix WH so this is
what we mean when we say we're concerned
about WH being small because if it's
smaller than the thing on the left has
to be exponentially small so in
particular in this paper that you can
click on at the bottom if you're
interested
pascale newest I'll showed that if the
largest eigenvalue of the weight matrix
wh is less than 1 then this gradients on
the left is going to shrink
exponentially and you can probably see
intuitively why this is true so if you
know as a simplifying assumption we
suppose that wh was not a matrix but
simply a scalar there was just a single
number then you could see why if that
number was greater than one then the
whole thing is going to explode and if
that number is less than one then it's
going to shrink exponentially as you
multiply by the same number again again
so you can check out the paper for more
details but here the bound is one
partially because it has a sigmoid
non-linearity and that's based on the
bounds of what we know is the norm of
the sigmoid function could be so this
shows you why if the wh matrix is small
or if it's largest eigenvalue is small
then we're going to have vanish
ingredients and similarly if you check
out the paper you can see that there's a
similar proof relating if the largest
eigenvalue is greater than 1/2 having
exposed ingredients so that's when the
gradients get bigger and bigger as you
backprop further okay so hopefully I've
convinced you that
vanch ingredients is a phenomenon that
happens in RN ants but I haven't yet
said why this is a problem so why should
we view this as a bad thing if the
gradients are getting larger and larger
or smaller and smaller as you bad
problem so here's a here's a picture
that might illustrate why it's a bad
thing so as before suppose that we're
thinking about what's the
of the loss on the fourth step with
respect to the first students days and
we have this situation where the
gradient is getting smaller and smaller
as it goes backwards but then think
about what is the gradient of let's say
the loss on the second step also with
respect to the first hidden state so I'm
representing that with the orange arrows
and what my point is here is that the
magnitude of the gradient signal from
close by is a lot bigger than the
far away and this means that when you
update your model weights the signal
that you're getting from close by is
going to be so much bigger than the
signal from far away that essentially
you're only going to learn you're only
going to optimize with respect to these
nearby effects and not the long-term
effects so you're going you're going to
lose the long term effects inside the
nearby effects any questions about this
yeah James not just one case so the
neuro term should have a certain loss
but you didn't hear I should have a
larger in fact as you know you are
updating the sum of the weights over
different chains
okay so I think the observation was that
given that for example language modeling
you might be summing over multiple
losses there's a loss in every step and
you sum all of them and that's your
overall loss then you do want to update
more with respect to the nearby losses
than the far losses so I think yeah so
if the design of your objective function
is that it's the sums allotted in every
step then you do want to wait all of
them equally I think my point was more
about what is the influence of the
action of the weight matrix at this
early stage
what is this influence on a loss that's
nearby and what is this influence on a
loss that's far away and due to the
dynamics of how the vanishing gradient
problem works then the influence on the
loss is far away is going to be much
less than the influence nearby and I'm
going to give some more linguistics
examples later of why you might want to
learn the connections that are further
away so essentially the problem is in
situations where you do want to learn
the connection between something that
happens early and something that happens
later then you're going to be unable to
learn that connection
so we'll see some motivation examples in
a minute any other questions on this
yeah you say why are you talking about
like pH like the j-th is like an H
parameter right yeah
w okay that's a great question so you're
asking why are we interested in some
kind of DJ by D H given that we're not
updating H HSN activation not a wait so
the reason why we're thinking about that
is because when you think about what is
DJ by T W which is a thing that we're
going to update that's always going to
be in terms of DJ by D H at some point
right so for thinking about W you know
and how it acts on the transformation
from h1 to h2 then DJ for by W in that
position is going to have to go through
DJ for by d h2 so if we're guessing
vanish ingredients as we back propagate
further then it's kind of like a
bottleneck then you're certainly going
to have banished ingredients as they
affect their recurrence matrix there and
indeed the matrix that supplies to the
inputs okay I'm gonna move on now so
another way to explain why vanish
ingredients is a problem is you can
think of it as gradient you can think of
it as a measure of the effect of the
past on the future so we've really
talked about this little bit gradient is
like saying if I change this weight or
as activation a little bit then how much
and how does it affect this thing in the
future so in particular if our gradient
is becoming vanishingly small over
longer distances let's say from step to
step T to step T plus n then we can't
tell whether in one of two situations so
the first situation is maybe there's no
dependency between step T and step T
plus M in the data so perhaps we're
learning on a task where in the task
there truly is no collect connection or
relationship to be learnt between what
happens on step T and what happens on
step T plus M so there truly is nothing
to be learnt and is actually correct
that there should be you know small
gradients with respect to those two
things but this
possibility is that yes there is a true
connection between those two things in
the data and in the task and really
ideally we should be learning that
connection but we have the wrong
parameters in our model to capture this
thing and therefore that is why the the
gradients are small because the model
doesn't see them as connected so we are
not learning the true dependency between
these two things and the problem with
the vanishing gradient problem is that
it's we're unable to tell in this
situation which of these two situations
were in okay so this is all pretty
theoretical I think this example should
make it a little more clear why the
vanishing gradient problem is bad so
last week we learned about RNN language
models and if you remember language
modeling is a task where you have some
kind of text and then you're trying to
predict what words come next so here's a
piece of text it says when she tried to
print her tickets she found that the
prince who was out of toner she went to
the stationery store to buy more toner
it was very overpriced after installing
the toner into the printer she finally
printed her and get someone shout out
what why do you think um next tickets
yes exactly so that was easy for you to
do because it makes sense logically that
if that was the thing she was trying to
do that's the thing she's going to do
once she's gone the whole detour for the
for the toner so the question is can our
NN language models easily answer this
question would they do well at this
particular language modeling example so
for an RNN language want to do well at
this kind of example then they need to
learn from this kind of example in the
training data so if it saw this example
in the training data then the RNN
language mother would need to model the
dependency learn the connection between
the appearance of the word tickets early
on on the seven-step and the target word
tickets at the end but if we have the
vanishing gradient problem then these
gradients of you know the step the last
step with respect to the early step is
going to be very small because it's a
fairly long distance right and this
means that the model is going to be
unable to learn this dependency easily
or at all so if the model can't learn is
kind of dependency during training then
the model is going to be unable to
predict similar kinds of long distance
dependencies the test time okay here's
another example here's a piece of text
the text says and this isn't a full
sentence
this is just a partial sentence it says
the writer of the books blank and I'm
going to give you two options
it's either the writer of the books is
or the writer of the books are so again
shout out which one do you think it is
is all yes that's right
so the correct answer a correct possible
continuation of the sentence would be
the right choice of books is planning a
sequel I can't think of a continuation
that goes the right where the books are
that would be Carrasco correct so the
reason why I'm bringing up this example
is because this shows a kind of tension
between two things called syntactic
recency and some sequential recency so
syntactic recency is the idea that in
order to correctly predict the next word
should be more is than are is that the
word writer is the kind of syntactically
closed word here so we say the writer of
the books is because it's the writer is
so you can see this as the word writer
and is a syntactically close because if
you looked at the dependency parts for
example then there would be a short path
in that tree so by contrast sir
sequential recency is the simpler
concept of how close words are just in
the sentence as a sequence of words so
in this example books and are a very
sequentially recent because they're
right next to each other so the reason
I'm bringing this up is because the
second one would be incorrect but it's
kind of a tempting option because if
you're mostly only paying attention to
things that happened recently then you
might get distracted and think of the
books are that sounds right so the
problem here is that our own image
models all that you're learning from
sequential recency than syntactic
recency and this is partially due to the
vanishing gradient problem because
especially perhaps if you're
syntactically related word is actually
kind of far away then it might get
really hard to use the information from
the syntactically recent word especially
if there's a lot of strong signal from
the sequentially recent word so there
are papers that show that RNN language
models make this kind of error of saying
are rather than is they make this kind
of error
more often than you would like
especially if you have multiple of these
distracting words such as books in
between the words you're trying to
predict and the true word that you
should be referring to okay any
questions on this all right moving on
so we briefly mentioned that explode
ingredients is a problem so I'm briefly
going to justify why is exploding
gradients a problem and why does it what
does it look like so the reason why
exploding gradients are a problem is if
you remember this is how SGG works we
say that the new parameters of the model
which we represent by theta is equal to
the old promises and then you take some
step in the direction of negative
gradients because you're trying to
minimize the last J so the problem is
that if your gradient gets really big
then your SGD update step is going to
become really big too so you're going to
be taking a very big step and you're
going to be drastically changing your
model parameters theta and this means
you can end up with some bad updates we
end up taking two larger step and we're
changing the parameters too much and
this means that we kind of take a big
step and we end up in some area where
the parameters are actually very bad
with example that for example they might
have much larger loss than they had
before so in the worst case this can
often manifest as seeing infinities or
Nan's not a number in your network when
you're training it in practice so this
can happen because if you take such a
big step that maybe you update your
parameters so much that now they're
infinity or minus infinity something
like that then you're gonna have all of
these infinities within your activations
as well and then all of your losses are
going to be infinity and the whole thing
just isn't going to work at all
so it's very annoying when this happens
and unfortunately happens fairly often
and if it does then you have to
essentially restart training from some
earlier checkpoint before you got the
Nance and the infinities because there's
no kind of salvaging it from its new
state so what's a solution to this
exploding gradient problem the solution
is actually pretty simple and it's this
technique called gradient clipping so
the main idea of gradient clipping is
that
if the norm of your gradient is greater
than some threshold and the threshold is
a hyper parameter that you choose then
you want to scale down that gradient
before you apply the SGD update so the
intuition is they're still gonna take a
step in the same direction you're going
to make sure that it's a smaller step so
here I've got a screenshot of some
pseudocode from the related paper that's
proposed creating clipping already some
version of gradient clipping and it's
pretty simple as you can see G hat is
the vector which is the derivative of
the error with respect to the parameters
and it's saying that if the norm of this
gradient is greater than the threshold
then you just scale it down but the
important thing to note is that it's
still pointing in the same direction
it's just a smaller step so here's a
picture to show how that might work out
in practice and this is a diagram from
the deep learning textbook which is also
linked on the website so what's going on
here is that the picture here is the
lost surface of a simple RM so they made
a very simple RN that instead of having
a sequence of vectors as the hidden
States
it's just suppose that each hidden state
is simply just a single scalar this
means that instead of having a weight
matrix W and a bias vector B you have a
scalar W in a scalar B so that's why in
the picture you just have this like two
dimensional parameter space and then the
the z axis is your is your loss
so here high loss is bad and low loss is
good and what you're trying to get so
here in this picture you've got this
kind of clip right you have this very
steep cliff face where the loss changes
very quickly and this cliff is really
dangerous because it has steep steep
gradients and you might be in danger of
taking a really big update step because
you're on the area with the really steep
gradient so on the Left you've got a
possible scenario of what might happen
if you don't have gradient clipping so
on the left you can see that you start
kind of at the bottom of the cliff and
you have a few small updates and then in
particular it makes a bad update because
you see there's a small kind of dip
before it goes up the cliff so this is a
true local minimum the optimum
you're trying to get to is at the bottom
of that small kind of ditch and it
starts off kind of near the edge of that
ditch and then there's a negative
gradient going into it but unfortunately
the the update kind of overshoots and it
ends up going a long way off the cliff
so now it's in this bad situation where
it's taking a Bad's update and now it's
got a much bigger loss than our before
so now that it's on the cliff again it
it measures the gradients and the
gradient is very steep right the
gradient is very large so when it takes
a update with respect to that gradients
then because the gradient is so big it
takes a really huge step and that's the
the one to the right you can see the
step going to the right so that's also
very bad update because it's just
throwing it really far to some probably
fairly random configuration of W and B
so on the left you can see what can go
wrong if you're taking these really big
steps because you want your areas with
very steep gradient so by contrast on
the right you can see what might happen
if you do have gradient clipping and
it's much less drastic right you've got
a similar kind of pattern where it takes
a few steps into the ditch and then it
ends up going up the cliff a little bit
but not too much because the gradient
was clips and then it's on the cliff and
there's again a really steep gradients
but it doesn't take such a big step
because again the gradient was clipped
so it kind of comes back down so you can
see the plausibly by using this gradient
clipping method you've got a kind of
safer update rule where you're not going
to take any any big crazy steps and
you're more likely to kind of find the
true minimum which is at the bottom of
the ditch I think there was a question
earlier I saw a question over here
anyways yep so the question is in
assignment 3 you saw the ads an
optimization algorithm which has this
thing called momentum which essentially
says that kind of like physical momentum
in the real world that if you've been
traveling in the same direction for a
while then you can take bigger steps I
think and if you've recently kind of
changed direction then you should take
smaller steps and I think there's
another element as well where you divide
by
some factor so it is a similar kind of
idea I suppose there's a different
criterion right so what they both have
in common is it's a kind of criterion
for when to scale up or scale down the
size of your update step and I think
they're based on different notions of
when should you take bigger steps and
when should you take small steps when
should be cautious or less cautious so I
guess here the criterion is different
it's kind of a simple criterion saying
like if it's really steep then be
careful yeah another question
which regulations okay so question is is
this similar to regularization of some
kind right
so I suppose yeah there is there are
some things in common so for example l2
regularization says that you want for
example your weight matrices to have a
small l2 norm right and the idea is that
you're trying to prevent to your model
from overfitting the data by I'm having
some kind of constraint that says you
have to keep your weights fairly simple
that is keep them you know small so I
suppose the relationship is that here
we're saying that we don't want the norm
of the gradients to be too big I don't
know if this is related to overfitting
and I guess I have to think more
carefully about that but I guess it's a
similar kind of constraint that you're
placing ok I'm gonna move on for now
so we've talked about how you might fix
the exploding gradient problem with
gradient clipping but we haven't talked
about how we might fix the vanishing
gradient problem
so to recap I think one way to
characterize the problem with the vanish
ingredients in our ends is that it's too
difficult for the RNN to learn to
preserve information over many time
steps so in our example with printing
the tickets and remembering that it's a
ticket so she wants to print you could
think of it as it's hard for the RNN
language model to correctly predict
tickets because in a way it's too hard
for the RN and lang trouble to learn to
retain the tickets information and use
it later so if you look at the equation
for vanilla RN ends and how we compute
the hidden state based on the previous
hidden state and the inputs you can see
that the hidden state is in a way
constantly being rewritten it's always
computed based on these linear
transformations and the you know the
non-linearity so it's not all that easy
to preserve the information from one in
the state to the other in particular
because we're putting it through this
non linearity function so this motivates
us to ask what about an RNN with some
kind of separate memory if we had some
kind of separate place to store
information that we wanted to use later
then would this make it easier for our
RNN to learn to preserve information
over many time steps so this is the
motivating idea behind Ella Siam's or
long short-term memory are nuns so the
idea here is that an LCM is a type of
RNN and it was pros back in 1997 and the
idea is that this is this was proposed
as an explicit solution to the vanishing
gradients problem so one of the main
differences here is that on each step T
instead of just having a hidden state HT
we have both a hidden state HT and a
sell state which we denote C T and both
of these are vectors of some same length
n and the idea is that the cell is meant
to store our long-term information
that's that's on memory units another
super important thing is that the LS TM
can arrays and writes and read
information from the cell so you kind of
think of this a bit like memory in a
computer and that you can do these
operations reading and writing and
erasing and that's how you're going to
keep your information another super
important thing is that the way the LS
TM decides whether it wants to arrays
writes read information and decide how
much and which information that's all
controlled by these gates so the idea is
that the gates are themselves also
vectors of length m and the idea is that
on each time step each element of these
gates which are vectors are somewhere
between 0 and 1 so here 1 represents an
open gate and 0 represents a closed gate
and you can have values anywhere in
between so the over idea which we're
going to firm up on the next slide but
the over idea is that if the gate is
open that represents some kind of
information being passed through and if
the gate is closed it means that
information does not pass through ok
it's the last really important thing is
that the gates are dynamic they're not
just set at some constant value for the
whole sequence they're dynamic which
means that they're different on each
time step T and their value that is the
decision of whether they're open or
closed and in which ways that is
computed based on the current context ok
so here's here's the the equations to
understand which might make it clearer
so suppose we have some sequence of
inputs XT and we want to compute a
sequence of hidden States HT and cell
states see T so this is what happens on
time step T this first set of equations
shows you the three gates that I talked
about before so the first one is called
the forget gates and the idea is that
this one is controlling what is kept
versus what is forgotten from the
previous cell state the previous memory
and you can see that this forget gates
is computed based on the previous hidden
state HT minus 1 and the current input
XT so that's what I meant when I said
that it's dynamic and it's computed
based on the current context you can
also see that it's computed using the
sigmoid function which means that it's
somewhere between 0 and 1 ok the next
gate is called the input gate and this
one controls what parts of the new cell
contents are written to the cell so the
idea is that you have this this memory
cell and this is kind of controlling
like how and what you get to write to
the memory cell ok and the last one is
called the output gate so this one is
controlling what parts of the cell are
outputs to the hidden state so you could
view this as kind of like the read
function right we're going to read some
information from our memory cell and
that's going to get put into our hidden
states and this gate it's gonna control
out ok
yeah that's just the sigmoid function as
we noted before all right so the next
set of equation shows how we use these
gates so the first line you could regard
this C tilde as the new cell contents so
this is the new content that you want to
write to the cell and this is also
computed based on your previous hidden
state in your current inputs and this
goes through at an age non-linearity so
this is kind of the the main content
that you are computing based on the
context and you want to write this
internet slang what's happening is that
we're going to use the forget gate to
selectively forget some of the
information from the previous memory
cell and you can see that we're doing
this L
Weis product that's what the little
circle is so the idea is if you remember
that F T is a vector full of values
between 0 & 1
when you do an element-wise product
between ft and the previous cell state
CT minus 1 then what you're essentially
doing is you're kind of masking out some
of the information from the previous
hidden state
sorry no previous cell stage so when F
is 1 then you're copying over the
information but when F is 0 then you're
getting rid of that information you are
raising in or for guess again ok and
then the other half of this equation I T
times C Tilda T that's the input gate
controlling which parts of the new cell
contents are going to get written
written to the to the cell okay and then
the last thing we do is we pass the cell
through a tonnage that's just adding
another non-linearity and then you pass
that through the output gates and that
gives you the intestate so in l STM's we
often think of the hidden states as
being like the outputs of the RNN and
the reason for this is that you kind of
view these cell states as being this
kind of internal memory that's not
generally accessible to the outside but
the hidden states are the parts you're
gonna pass on to the next part of the
model so that's why we view it as kind
of like the output of the model and this
is yeah just reminder that those circles
are element-wise products and that's how
we apply the gates I don't have any
questions about this ok so as a reminder
all of these are vectors of some
Symington okay so some people learn
better from diagrams than equations and
here's a diagram presentation of the
same idea so this is a really nice
diagram from a blog post by Chris Ola
about LS TMS and that's a good place to
start if you want to get an intuitive
understanding of what STM's are so in
this diagram the green boxes represent
time steps and that zoom in on the
middle one see what's happening here so
within one time step you can see that
this diagram is showing exactly the same
thing as
six equations showed on the previous
slide so the first thing we do is we use
the the current input XT which is at the
bottom and the previous hidden state HT
minus one on the left and we can use
that computer forget gate and you can
see F T is on that arrow there and then
you apply the forget gate to the
previous cell and that's the same thing
as forgetting some of the the cell
content for the last time okay and then
after that you can compute the input
gates and that's computed in much the
same way as the forget gate and then you
use the implicates to decide which parts
of this new cell contents get written to
the cell and that gives you the cell C T
so here you can see that you compute the
IMP you get input gates and the new
contents and then you use that to gate
that and write it to the cell so now
I've got our new cell C T and then the
last things we need to do is compute our
new output gate that's ot and then
lastly use the output gate to select
which parts of the cell contents you're
going to read and put in the new hidden
state HT so that's that's that's the
same thing as the equations we saw on
the previous slide okay so that's other
CMS why are we applying at an edge on
the very last equation on this on this
slide why are we planning at an h2 the
cell before applying the output gate
let's see yeah so your question is that
the cell the new cell content already
went through at an age I'm not sure so I
suppose a general answer is that it must
be giving some kind of more expressivity
some way and that it's not just applying
teenagers sequentially because you do
have the gates in between
so I suppose there must be a reason kind
of similarly to when you apply apply a
linear lay you want to have a
non-linearity before the next linear
layer I suppose maybe we're viewing
these cases are kind of linear layer
oh sure I'll look it up okay so that's
Alice yemm's and if you recall we were
Oh question forget cake you don't look
at the previous cell state or you just
look at the new end state and it seems
like if you're just deciding what to
forget from the cell state you should
look at it so the question is why is the
forget gate computed only from the
previous hidden state and the current
input why is it not computed based on CT
minus 1 itself rakish or do you want to
look at the thing to figure out whether
you want to forget it or not that's a
pretty good question
so I suppose one reason why you might
think that this this works fine is that
the lsdm might be learning a general
algorithm for where it stores different
types of information in the cell right
so maybe it's learning that in this
particular position in the cell I learn
information about this particular
semantic thing and then in this
situation I want to use that or not use
that forget it or keep it but yeah I
haven't entirely convinced myself why
you don't want to look at the contents
of the cell itself in order to decide I
suppose another thing to notice is that
HT minus 1 was read from CT minus 1 so I
suppose there is some information there
but not necessarily all of the
information yeah I'm not sure that's
another thing I need to look up I guess
any other questions
okay so though that's on the CMS and LOC
ons were introduced to try to solve the
vanishing gradient problem so the
question is Oh
how exactly is this architecture making
the banchon gradient problem any better
so you could see that the LS TM
architecture actually makes it easier
for RN ends to preserve information over
many time stubs
so while it was kind of difficult for
the middle RNN to preserve the
information over all of the hidden
states there's actually a fairly easy
strategy that makes it simple for the
LSC m to preserve the information so
namely if the forget gate is set to
remember everything on every step that's
a fairly simple strategy that will
ensure that the information in the cell
is going to be preserved indefinitely
over many time steps so I don't know if
that's actually a good strategy for
whatever task you're trying to do but my
point is that there is at least a fairly
straightforward way for the LS TM to
keep the information over many steps and
as we noted that's relatively harder for
the vanilla or an entity so you can
think of this as the key reason why LS
TMS are more able to preserve the
information and thus are more about to
the vanishing gradient problem however I
think you should still know that LS TMS
don't necessarily guarantee that we
don't have a vanishing or exploding
gradient problem you could still have
that problem but the thing to remember
is that it's easier to avoid it in a way
okay so LS TMS have been shown to be
more robust to the vanishing graining
problem but I'm going to tell you a
little about how they've actually been
more successful in real life without a
question
okay so it's a great question the
question is why is it that just because
you have these LS TM to find forward
equations why do you not have the ranch
ingredient problem why does the the the
logic about the chain rule kind of
getting smaller and smaller or bigger
and bigger not apply so I think the key
here is that in the vanilla RNN the
hidden states are kind of like a
bottleneck right like all gradients must
pass through them so if that gradient is
smaller than all downstream grains will
be small whereas here you could regard
the cell as being kind of like a
shortcut connection at least in the case
where the forget gate is set to remember
things then that's kind of like a
shortcut connection where the cell will
stay the same if you have the forget
gate set to remember things so if this
cell is staying mostly the same then you
are not going to be having the vanishing
gradient by the cell so that means that
to get a connection from the gradient of
something in the future with respect to
something in the past there is a
potential route for the gradient to go
via the cell that doesn't necessarily
vanish so I think the question was how
do you check that your gradients are
correct given that there are now
multiple routes for information to
travel so I suppose this somewhat
relates to what we talked about last
time with the multivariable chain rule
about what is the derivative of the loss
with respect to and repeated weight
matrix and we saw that if there are
multiple routes then the multivariable
chain rule says that you add up the
gradients so if your question is how do
you do the calculations correct I guess
you just kind of apply the multivariable
chain rule and it's more calm
Asians assessing with the LS TMS if
using PI torch 214 you have to do that
yourself if you're going to implement it
yourself then you might have a more
difficult time yeah so I guess it yeah
okay alright so where do we get to all
right so we're about to talk about Ella
stems and how they work in the in the
real world so in the pretty recent past
2013 2015 LS TM started achieving a lot
of state of the art results on a variety
of different tasks including for example
handwriting recognition speech
recognition machine translation pausing
image captioning so over this period
Alice TMS became the dominant approach
in a lot of these application areas
because they worked convincingly a lot
better than vanilla our names
however today in 2019 things change
pretty fast in deep learning so other
approaches for example transformers
which is going to learn about later in
the class in some of these application
areas they seem to have become the
dominant approach so to look into this I
had a look at WMT which is a machine
translation conference and also
competition where people submit their MT
systems to be evaluated and I looked at
the reports the summary report from WMTW
their MT systems based on RN ends and in
particular Alice tiems
and then I look to the report from 2018
just two years later and I found that
the RN n the word RN n only appeared
nine times and the word transformer
appeared 63 times and in fact the
organizers noted that everyone what most
people seem to using transformers now so
there shows that things change pretty
fast in deep learning the thing that was
hot and new just a few years ago is now
being passed by perhaps by other kinds
of approaches so you're going to learn
more about transformers later but I
guess that gives you a kind of idea of
where Alice TMS are currently in
applications okay so the second kind of
rnm ago learned about is gated recurrent
units
so these fortunately are simpler than as
TMS in fact that was
the motivation for them being post their
post in 2014 as a way to try to retain
the strengths of LS DMS but getting rid
of any unnecessary complexities so
energy are you we don't have the cell
state we again just have a hidden state
but the thing it has in common with
other stands is that we're going to be
using gates to control the flow of
information so here are the equations
for a GRU we start off with two gates so
the first gate is called the update gate
and this controls what parts of the
hidden states are going to be updated
versus preserved so you can kind of view
this as playing the role of both the
forget gate and the input gates in the
lsdm and it's computers in much the same
way as the gates in the lsdm wha
the second gate is called the reset
gates RT and the idea is that this gate
is controlling which parts of the
previous hidden state are going to be
used to compute new contents so you can
think of the the reset gate is kind of
selecting which parts of the previous
hidden states are useful versus not
useful so it's going to discard some
things and select some other things okay
so here's how those gates get used h
tilde here this is you can think of it
as the new hidden state content and
what's going on in that equation is that
we are applying the reset gate to the
previous hidden state HT minus 1 and
then putting all of that through some
linear transformations and at an H and
then this gives us the new content which
we want to write to the hidden self and
then lastly our new hidden cell is going
to be a combination of this new content
and the previous hidden States so the
important thing to notice here is that
we have this one minus U and Utah so
it's kind of like a balance right U is
is setting the balance between
preserving things from the previous
hidden state versus writing new stuff so
whereas in the LS TM those were two
completely separate gates that could be
whatever value here we have this
constraint that you as being a balance
so if you have more of one you have to
have less of the other so this is one
way in which the creators of the G
you sought to make LS CMS more simple
was by having a single gate play both of
these roles okay so that's G I use and I
think it's a little less obvious just
looking at it
why G I use help the vanishing greatest
problem because there is no explicit
memory so like there is no stems so I
think the way to look at this here is G
OU's you can view this as also being a
solution to the vanishing gradient
problem because like Alice GM's G OU's
make it easier to retain information
long-term so for example here if the
update gates UT is set to zero then
we're going to be keeping the hidden
state the same on every step and again
that's maybe not a good idea but at
least that is a strategy you can easily
do in order to retain information over
long distances so that's kind of like
the same explanation of how do I use
make it potentially easier for RNs to
retain information long term okay
so we've learned about these two
different types of yes I'm creating
these two your gates I think the
question was did we view these two gates
in the GRU as being a precise analogy to
the gates in the STM or are they more of
a fuzzy analogy I'd say probably more of
a fuzzy analogy because there are other
changes going on in here like for
example the fact that there's no
separate memory cell means that they're
not performing exactly the same
functions yeah
okay so we learnt about LST M's and Gi
use which are both more complicated
forms of RN ends more complicated than
vanilla RN ends and they are both more
robust to the vanishing gradient problem
so it were useful to know which of these
should be using in practice which one is
more successful the LST M or GRU so I
did a little reading and it looks like
researchers have proposed a lot of
different types of gated RN ends so it's
not just GI using a CMS as many other
papers with lots of other different
variants but these are definitely the
two that are most widely used and you
can probably say that the biggest
difference between the two for sure is
the fact that GI use are simpler and
quicker to compute and they have fewer
parameters so this makes an actual
practical difference to you as a deep
learning practitioner because if you
build your net based on G or use then
it's going to be faster to run forwards
and you know faster to Train and so on
so other than that there appears to be
no very conclusive evidence that one of
these alistair Modi I use is
consistently outperforming the other on
lots of different tasks
it seems that often sometimes GI use do
you perform as well as lcms but there
are cases where one of them performs
best than the other so as a rule of
thumb it seems like STM is often a good
default choice to start with especially
if your data has particularly long
dependencies because there's evidence to
think that other students might be
slightly better at keeping information
over very long distances and also if you
have a lot of training data you might
think that l STM's are a better choice
because they have more parameters which
means that maybe you need more training
data to learn them so a rule of thumb is
that maybe you want to start with those
TMS and if you're happy with our
performance and happy with how long it
takes to train then you stick with that
but if you feel like you need it to be
more efficient then maybe you should
switch to GI use and see how that goes
with the performance and if it's faster
alright so we've talked so far about how
the vanishing exploding gradients are a
problem that occur a lot in our ends but
the question is is it only an RNN
problem does this occur and other kinds
of neuron networks as well and the
answer is no it's not just our own
in fact eventually explode ingredients
are a pretty significant problem for
most neural architecture such as feed
forward and convolutional especially
when they're deep and this is a really
serious problem because there's no point
having a really cool neural architecture
if you can't learn it efficiently
because of the vanishing gradient
problem so in particular in these
feed-forward a convolutional networks
you often have a gradient becoming
vanishingly small over back propagation
because of the chain rule because of
this multiplied by all these different
intermediate gradients or sometimes due
to your choice of non-linearity function
so if this happens this means that
you're the lower layers of your let's
say convolutional or feed-forward
network they have a much smaller
gradient than the high levels and this
means that they get changed very slowly
during SGG so this means that overall
your network is very slow to Train
because when you take updates then your
lower layers are changing very slowly so
one solution kind of like a family of
solutions that we've seen in recent
years is that there's been lots of
proposals for new types of deep feed
forward or convolutional architectures
and what they do is they add more direct
connections in the network and the idea
kind of as we talked about before is
that if you add all of these direct
connections between layers like maybe
not just adjacent layers but further
part layers then it makes it much easier
for the gradients to flow and you're
going to find it easier to train your
network overall so I'm going to show you
some examples of these in particular
because it's fairly likely you're going
to run into these kinds of architectures
when you're doing your projects and
reading papers so one example is
something called residual connections or
the network itself or sometimes referred
to as res Nets and here we've got a
figure from their related paper so
what's going on in this diagram is that
you have the usual kind of you've got
weight layer and a non-linearity which
is rare you and another weight layer so
if you regard that function as being f
of X what they're doing is instead of
just transforming X to f of X they're
taking f of X plus X so they're adding
this identity skip connection where the
input X is skipped over those two layers
and then added
to the output of the two layers so the
reason why this is a good idea
also known as skip connections is that
the identity connection is going to
preserve information by default right so
if you imagine perhaps if you initialize
your network and you initialize your
wait layers to have small random values
then if they're they're small and kind
of close to zero then you're going to
have something like a noisy identity
function right so you're going to be
preserving information by default
through all of your layers and if you
have a very deep network that means that
even after many many layers you're still
going to have something like your
original inputs so the people who wrote
this paper they show that if you don't
have something like skip connections
then actually you can find that deep
layers deep networks perform worse on
some tasks than shallow networks not
because they're not expressive enough
but because they're too difficult to
learn so when you attempt to learn the
deep networks it just doesn't learn
effectively and you end up getting worst
performance in the shallow network so
the people who read this paper they show
that when they add these skip
connections then they made the deep
networks much more effective and they
managed to get good performance so
another example which kind of takes this
idea further is something called dense
connections or dense Nats and again this
was something proposed I think in a feed
forward or convolutional setting and
it's just kind of the same skip
connections bit except connects
everything to everything so add more of
these skip connections kind of from all
layers to all layers and they show that
this performs even better and the last
one I want to talk about which I have a
picture for is something called highway
connections so this is similar to the
residual or skip connections but the
idea is that instead of just adding your
X adding your identity connection the
idea is you're going to have a gate that
controls the balance between adding the
identity and computing the
transformation so instead of FX plus X
you're going to have you know gate x FX
plus you know 1 minus K times X
something like that so this work was
actually inspired by LS TMS but instead
of applying it to a recurrent setting
they were seeking to apply it to a
feed-forward setting
okay I'm gonna keep going for now so
overall the question was you know how
much vanishing expert ingredients a
problem outside of the setting of our
hands and I think the important takeaway
is that it is a big problem but you
should notice that it is particularly a
problem for our hands
so Ireland's are particularly unstable
and this is essentially due to the
repeated multiplication by the same
weight matrix if you remember from last
time the characteristic thing about our
n ends that makes them recurrent is the
fact that you're applying the same
weight matrix over and over again so
this is actually the the core reason why
they are so prone to the vanishing
exponent in gradients and you can see
some more information about that in the
paper okay so I know there's been a lot
of dense information today a lot of
large notation so here's a recap if I've
lost you at any point now is a good time
to jump back in because it's going to
get a little easier to understand
perhaps so ok recap what have we learnt
about today the first stimulant about
was the vanishing gradient problem we
learn what it is we learn why happens
and we saw why it's bad for our own ends
for example RNN language models and we
also learnt about LST M's and Gi use
which are more complicated our n ends
and they use gates to control the flow
of information and by doing that they
are more as an into the vanishing
gradient problem okay so if the remains
of selection oh you think we've got
about 20 minutes left we're going to be
learning about two more advanced type of
our hands so the first one is
bi-directional are n ends and that's all
about information flowing left to right
and right to left and then we're also
going to learn about multi-layer RN ends
which is when you apply multiple are
announced on top of each other so I'd
say the both of these are pretty simple
conceptually so shouldn't be too too
hard to understand alright so let's
start with bi-directional RN ends this
is a picture which you saw at the end of
last lecture so if you remember
sentiment classification is the task
when you have some kind of input
sentence such as the movie was terribly
exciting and you want to classify this
as positive or negative sentiments so in
this example it should be seen as
positive sentiment so this is an example
of how you might try to solve sentiment
classification using a fairly simple RNN
model
here we're using the RNN as a kind of
encoder of the sentence and the hidden
states represent the sentence and we'll
do some kind of combination of the
hidden states to compute what we think
the sentiment is so my question is if we
look at let's say the hidden state that
corresponds to the word terribly and
we're regarding this hidden state as a
representation of the word terribly in
the context of the sentence so for this
reason we see some is called hidden
states in this kind of situation a
contextual representation because the
idea is this is a representation of the
word terribly in the context of the
sentence so the thing to think about
here is that this contextual
representation it only contains
information about the left context
so for terribly the left context is the
words the movie was and this hidden
state the one that's got the blue box
around it has only seen information to
the left it hasn't seen the information
of the words exciting or exclamation
mark so what we're asking is what about
the right context the right context of
terribly is the word exciting and the
exclamation mark and do we think that
the right context is useful here do we
think that this is something we want to
know about and I would argue that in
this example it is actually kind of
important because we've got the phrase
terribly exciting and if you look at the
word terribly in isolation terrible or
terribly usually mean something bad
right but terribly exciting usually
means something good because it just
means very exciting so if you know about
the right context the words exciting
then this might quite significantly
modify your perception of the meaning of
the word terribly in the context of this
sentence and especially given that we're
trying to do sentiment classification
this is this is kind of important so
this motivates why you might want to
have information from both the left and
the right when you're making your
representations if when you're a kids
your parents told you to look both ways
before you cross the street you might
regard it as the same kind of idea that
there's useful information to the left
and the right that you'd like to know
about before you do anything okay so
that's the motivation and here's how a
bi-directional rnm might work in
practice I have a kind of accidentally
festive color scheme here so the idea is
that you have two rnns going on
you have the forward RNN as
for that encodes the sentence left to
right and then separately you also have
a backwards RNN and this has completely
separate weights to the forward RM so
the backward RNN is just doing the same
thing except that it's encoding the
sequence from right to left so each of
the hidden state is computed based on
the one to the right and then finally
you just take the hidden States from the
two Arlen's and then you can catenate
them together and you've got your your
final kind of representations so in
particular if we now think about this
context tree representation of the word
terribly in the context this this vector
has information from both the left and
the right right because he had the
forwards and the backwards horns that
respect that they had information from
both left and right so the ideas of
these um concatenated hidden states
those can be regarded as kind of like
the outputs of the bi-directional RNN
like if you're going to use these hidden
States for any kind of further
computation then it's these concatenated
hidden states that you're going to be
passing on to the next part of the
network here here in the equations that
just say the same thing so you have your
forward RNN and here we've got a
notation that you might not have seen
before this kind of notation versus R
and N and then in brackets the previous
hidden state and the input that's simply
saying that you know HT is computed from
the previous hidden States and the
inputs and RN n forward could be a
vanilla or a GRU or an LS TM it doesn't
really matter so we're looking at it
abstractly so you have these two
separate RN ends are n n forwards and RN
are backwards and generally these have
separate weights although I have seen
some papers where they have shared ways
so it seems that sometimes that does
work better perhaps maybe when you have
a des training data and then finally we
regards these concatenated hidden states
which you might just notice HT as being
like the hidden states of the
bi-directional or an M so the previous
diagram is pretty unwieldy so here's a
simplified diagram and this is probably
the only kind of diagram you're going to
see from now on to denote by direction
RN ends so all we've done here is we've
just made all of the horizontal arrows
go left and right
represent that this is a bidirectional
RM so the other thing you should assume
is that the hidden states depicted here
you know these red red trying red
rectangles with the dots you can assume
that those that they're concatenated
forwards backwards hidden States from
the bi-directional rnm okay so the
question is would you train your
forwards and backwards RN ends kind of
separately on some kind of task and then
maybe concatenate them together once
they're separately trained networks or
would you train them all together it
seems to me that it's much more common
to train them together but I don't think
I've heard of anyone training them
separately so yeah it seems like the
standard practice is usually to train
them together so that's suppose that we
were trying to build a sentient
classification system using the
bi-directional RNN then what you do
which maybe I should have pictured red
in that space is you would do the same
thing that you were doing with the
uni-directional RNN which was let's say
an element-wise mean or max to get your
sentence encoding maybe you just do that
but over the concatenated ends dates
okay so an important thing to note is
that when talking about applying
bi-directional RN ends we've assumed
that we actually have access to the
entire input sequence so we assumed that
we had the full sentence the movie was
very exciting and that that was a
necessary assumption in order to be able
to run the forwards and the backwards or
an M right so there are some situations
where you can't assume this life example
in language modeling you only have
access to the left context kind of by
definition of the task you only know the
words have come so far you don't know
what's coming next so you can't use a
bi-directional RNN to do language
modeling in the way that we've depicted
here because you don't have the for
sequence however if you do have access
to the entire sequence so for example if
you're doing any kind of encoding
similar to this sentiment example
then bi-directionally bidirectionality
is pretty powerful and usually probably
regarded as a good thing to do by
default because it turns out they're
getting this information from both the
left and the right makes a lot easier to
learn these more useful contextual
representations so in particular as a
preview of something you're going to
learn about later in the class there's a
model called Bert BER T and that stands
for bi-directional encoder
representations from transformers and
this is a pretty recently like a few
months ago proposed system and it's this
pre-trained contextual representation
system and it's heavily reliant on the
idea of bidirectionality it turns out
that the bi-directional nature of Bert
is pretty important to its success so
you can learn more about that later but
that's just an example of how
bidirectionality you can give you much
more powerful contextual representations
okay so the last thing we're gonna talk
about today is multi layer RNAs so you
could regard rnns is already being deep
in some sense because you already unroll
them over potentially very many time
steps and you could regard that as a
kind of depth right but there's another
way that RNs could be deep so for
example if you applied multiple RN ends
kind of one after another then this
would be a different way to make your RN
and deep and this is the idea between
behind multi layer RM so the reason why
you would want to do this is because
this might allow the network to compute
more complex representations so this is
the logic that's right behind deep
networks in general so if you're
familiar with the idea of Y deeper is
better for let's say convolutional
networks then this is kind of the same
logic it's saying that your low RN ends
might be computing lower level features
like let's suppose maybe it's just a
track of syntax and your higher level RN
ends are going to compute high level
features like maybe semantics and a note
on terminology these are sometimes
called stacked Arnett's so this works
much as you'd imagine so here's an
example of how a multi-layer RN might
work if it's three layers so this is a
unidirectional RNN but it could be
bi-directional
if you had access to the entire input
sequence so I guess the the main thing
is that the hidden States from one RNN
layer are going to be used as the input
to the RNN layer that's coming next any
questions on this yeah that's a great
question so the question I think is
about the order of competition like what
order will you compute all of these
hidden States in I suppose there's some
flexibility right but you could compute
all of the step one ones like all of the
V ones and then all of the movie ones or
you could do all of our n n layer one
and then all of our n n layer two so
it's I think that when you you know call
the PI to watch function to do a
multi-layer RNN it will do all of our an
N layer 1 then 2003 that's what I think
happens but it seems like logically
there's no reason why you couldn't do it
yep that's a great point as well so
someone pointed out that if they were
bi-directional then you no longer have
that flexibility you would have to do
all of layer wine before layer 2 yeah
good point
anyone else ok so mostly our n ends in
practice these tens have come pretty
well in that when I look at our n n
based systems that are doing very well
on some kind of tasks they usually are
some kind of multi-layer RN n but they
certainly aren't as deep as the deep
convolutional feed-forward networks you
might have seen in for example image
tasks so whereas you know very deep
commnets I think hundreds of layers now
you certainly aren't getting Oran ends
that are that deep so for example in
this paper from Google they're doing
this kind of large hyper parameter
search for a neural machine translation
to find which kinds of high parameters
work well nmt and in this paper they
found that two to four layers was best
to the encoder
and four layers was best for the decoder
Doronin you'll find out more about what
encoder and decoder mean next time but
those are fairly small numbers although
they did find that if you add these skip
connections or these dense connections
then it makes it much easier to learn
some even deeper rnns more effectively
like maybe up to eight layers but these
certainly aren't hundreds of layers deep
and one of the reasons why rnns don't
tend to be nearly as deep as those other
kinds of networks is that because as we
commented before our own ends have to be
computed sequentially they can't be
computed in parallel this means that
they're pretty expensive to compute if
you have this depth in like two
dimensions you have the depth over the
time steps and then the depth over the
RNN layers to then it began it becomes
very very expensive to compute these
these are ends so that's another reason
why they don't get very deep so again to
just mention transformers you're going
to learn about transformers later but
these it seems can be deeper from from
what I can tell over what people are
using these days transform based
networks can be pretty deep so Burt for
example there's a 24 layer version and a
12 player version and admittedly that
was trained by Google and they have a
lot of computational power but I think
part of the reason why these transformer
based networks can be quite deep is that
they have a lot of these skipping light
connections in fact the whole innovation
of transformers is that they're built on
a loss of kind of skip connections okay
any questions Rama's son okay all right
so here's a summary of what we've
learned today I know it's been a lot of
information but I think here are full
practical takeaways from today that are
probably useful to you in your projects
even if you even if you didn't find very
interesting in themselves that probably
pretty useful so the first one is that
LS VMs are very powerful there's
certainly a lot powerful than more
powerful than vanilla are dense geo is
also more powerful than irv noren ins
and the only difference that is
consistently the same is that G I use
are faster than Earth dams the next one
is that you should probably clip your
gradients because if you don't clip your
gradients you're in danger of walking
off cliffs and then ending up with Nan's
in your model
the next tip is that bidirectionality is
useful if you can apply it and basically
any time when you have access to the
entire input sequence you can apply by
directionality so you should probably do
that by default and then the last tip is
that multi-layer rnns
are pretty powerful and again you should
probably do that if you have enough
computational power to do so but if
you're going to make your modular RNN
pretty deep then you might need to skip
connections all right thanks